c'est la plus grande fête en trois ans à
Taïwan le premier défilé de la fierté
avec public depuis le début de la
pandémie
ce n'est pas la pluie qui allait arrêter
les célébrations
[Musique]
cette 20e édition célèbre les progrès
réalisés Taïwan et fier d'être perçu
comme un bastion de la diversité
[Musique]
je me sens accepté aujourd'hui et j'ai
confiance en moi
[Musique]
il y a trois ans Taïwan a été le premier
endroit en Asie à légaliser le mariage
entre conjoint de même sexe
pour les visiteurs la petite île de 24
millions de personnes se veut un modèle
d'ouverture et de tolérance
les réalisations des dernières décennies
à Taïwan il y a aussi un sentiment de
travail inachevé
les organismes de défense des droits de
la communauté LGBT réclame entre autres
le droit à l'adoption pour les conjoints
de même sexe ainsi que l'élargissement
du droit au mariage
pour le moment seuls les conjoints de
même sexe provenant de pays où le
mariage gay est légal peuvent se marier
les Taïwanais ayant des conjoints
japonais coréens ou thaïlandais n'ont
donc pas le droit
le travail d'éducation doit aussi se
poursuivre selon elle il y a encore une
partie de la population qui refuse
d'accepter la communauté LGBT
qu'il soit militants de longue date tout
participant pour la première fois les
célébrations de la diversité ne font que
commencer des activités sont aussi
prévues dimanche ici Philippe Leblanc
Radio-Canada